when you guys were cast i am so curious
what did jeb tell you in terms of like
the arc of your character
how like how long you could be on the
show for because the thing about vikings
is you know characters come and go
it's true um when i learned i was on the
show i was really excited to um hear
about you know the world that jeb has
created he has woven such an intricate
you know tapestry of the universe and
i know you know i was a big fan of
vikings and i know you can die like with
the blink of an eye
um but i also love about jeb is that he
is such an incredible storyteller you
know you come in and you ask him one
little question i'm like hey jab what do
you think like the house looked like and
then all of a sudden he's like and then
this happens and then this happens
so there's you know there's a very rich
richness to the story and the universe
is is big so
fingers crossed you know we get to play
them for
well i get to play freitas for a long
long period of time the writers they did
a wonderful job and you mean the history
and the story is so rich
and so much is happening and in real
history as well you know so there's like
a wonderful just like a
story to tap from you know so yeah
one of the things that struck me was the
scope the ambition of this series in the
the first five episodes especially the
level of action how many places it takes
place for you both of you what was it
like reading these scripts and seeing
what they were going for with the scale
and scope
i was just reading it and going like wow
this is expensive
you know you read it and then there's
like and olaf arrives with 40 ships and
they pull down there they do that and
freitas fights all of these people and
but all jokes aside it was incredible to
work on something where
each and every single person that work
on this project really works so
incredibly hard they give it their best
and i feel like every day you would show
up on set and you'd be blown away by the
detail of everything and
it's it's just incredible really to um
to to visit the sets it's it's uh the
scale is just huge yeah it's amazing you
know and everything every little detail
also the costumes you know i mean not if
you want to go to the restroom i mean
forget about that because it's not it's
not sewn in the modern contemporary way
so even the dresses the arms the
everything is just like oh my god in the
always even into the details so you have
to time that as well you know
and you know for me i had a lot of big
dresses and boots and blah so you know
so but the scale of it was i mean i
tried to play cool the first days but my
i was just like
what you know i've never seen real life
biking ships on like on that level on
that size you know so it's amazing and
very
very very uh fun to be part of this
speaking of the costumes uh they're
incredible and i'm just curious who
borrowed what from set with every
intention of bringing it back
we can't spill the beans on that one can
we
[Laughter]
i'll leave it alone i won't you know um
uh but one of the things because it's an
ensemble show you guys were filming in
ireland obviously you're not on set
every day so what was it actually like
when you're not filming because of all
the covet protocols were you sort of
like you know stuck in a hotel all the
time or you know what i mean like how
did that work
yeah when we filmed season one it was we
the world was still learning about
corona we didn't really know how to work
with it there was no vaccine so it was
very learning by doing and you know
netflix and mgm took every precaution
they could to protect us and everyone
else working on set
so we were pretty shielded off from from
the world and thankfully i have you know
my scene partner caroline um so when you
know we were not working on set we could
go hiking in the wicklow mountains or
you know go for tea or just you know
read a book together or have a glass of
wine and talk
so um the beauty with working in the
pandemic is
we
really became a little vikings valhalla
family and i feel like we became so
incredibly close that no matter if you
know the show is continuing or not
we've all made friends for life and it's
always going to have such a huge place
in my heart
yeah and i think that reflects on the
series as well
the bond that we have that frida and i
have because we connected because we
were like in that coveted bubble
together now we love each other and but
sort of that bomb because we couldn't go
home we couldn't go anywhere so i think
you really see that
through the screen you know
what's also cool is for for people that
are about to love this show you know
you're going to get eight episodes but
you guys have already filmed season two
which is awesome normally it's like what
can you tease about season two you've
already filmed it so i'm going to ask
you what can you tease about
i know you can say that
um i so wish i could tell you
but uh let's continue this conversation
in the future i mean
then we can talk all about it now it's
like ah just season one is so exciting
oh oh
like i said this show is gonna be a huge
hit that's not like that's not open for
debate um i love learning about like the
behind the scenes of the making of a
show so for both of you what do you
think soon to be fans would be surprised
to learn about the making of vikings
valhalla i think they would be surprised
to learn that you know we have
the most incredible stunt team that
actually you know they make us they
share their work into shape so that we
do
the majority 99 of all this fighting
ourselves
um
i think that's pretty rare um
we actually were gifted with so much
time to work with them so we could
really really really you know perform
everything ourselves
um
i think people would be surprised to
hear that and also i someone told me i'm
not sure if it's correct that we have
the world's largest like historical
viking fleet isn't that badass oh wow
so many i must say yeah
i mean who else who else would have like
40 viking ships at home exactly but i
think also people would be surprised of
the
friendship also because that it was like
such a strong bond between all the
characters in evil on screen some
you know you would not interfere because
there will be christians and pagans but
behind the scenes we were all really
really good friends and i think also
because of the again pandemic you know
because if we had each other it's like
one big happy family i think people will
be very surprised to see us hanging out
with each other actually loving each
other backstage yeah absolutely yeah
on that and that note i gotta wrap again
i just want to say congrats good luck
with the rest of your speed dating and
thank you for talking with me